salut maroni
a là je vais à la rencontre d'un
agriculteur qui a bénéficié de l'aide du
département pour améliorer sa production
désolé je peux pas t'en dire plus je
dois y aller je suis en retard à lire
plus tard je te rappelle tout à l'heure
désolé
vous aussi vous voulez savoir de quelle
plantations il s'agit alors resté avec
moi
[Musique]
e
nous sommes à piton saint leu sur le
domaine de frédéric frédéric il ya un an
a décidé d'augmenter sa production pour
y faire pousser de bons petits fruits
pays un projet qu'il a pu mettre en
place avec l'aide du département suivez
moi c'est par là
bonjour fédérer toujours qu'est ce que
vous faites pousser ici même effet
poussé principalement des agrumes citron
combat va un peu d'eux à poitiers aussi
comme la mangue papaye là mais c'est
d'aller dans des techniques de culture
agro écologiques que je vais aller dans
le bios chypre ojjeh des bons des bons
fruits essayer de faire de désherbage
manuel on se rend compte que c'est très
pénible et jo grâce aux départements ils
nous donnent un soutien financier et
aussi administratifs j'ai bénéficié de
3000 euros pour la plantation et le
dossier c'est toi personnellement qu'il
a remplie c'est assez compliqué pour
nous agriculteurs de la cellule qui est
en place mais nous aident pour le
montage du dossier quel papier il faut
tout ça c'est vraiment un gros soutien
de leurs de leurs parents
[Musique]
pour accompagner les agriculteurs locaux
à développer leur activité le
département propose des aides et déploie
une équipe de professionnels partout sur
l'île quand florence experte des aides
spécifiques agricole bonjour florence
genre alexandre alors on était avec
frédéric mais de quel type dead il a pu
bénéficier alors c'est une aide
spécifique aux producteurs indépendants
de fruits et légumes pourquoi ce
dispositif a été mis en place donc fait
c'est pas un groupe d'agriculteurs
indépendant du sud qui a interpellé le
département pour les aider à maintenir
des cultures concurrencer et ce
dispositif a été mis en place et étendue
à tous les agriculteurs qui ont la même
difficulté donc il ya des cultures
concurrencer comme l'ail l'oignon la
pomme de terre la carotte mais il ya
aussi des cultures identitaire comme le
curcuma le gingembre la lentille et
notre petit piment payos pour revenir à
frédéric comme on vous l'avait
accompagnée au niveau du département des
coudes quand le dispositif sort il est
largement diffusée au niveau médiatique
sur le site du département et avec les
partenaires et on en voit aussi des
textos donc ensuite il ya une permanence
qui se met en place on les aide à monter
le dossier mais il faut faire quoi pour
voir que c'est assez raide il faut être
agriculteur à titre principal
indépendant et il faut aussi cultivé -
une de ses douze sculptures merci
florent garcia toi alexandre
pendant l'évolution des dossiers les
agents du département s'impliquent
échanges et créer des liens avec les
bénéficiaires derrière ces dispositifs
ce sont bien des réunionnais qui
soutiennent d'autres réunionnais connais
que l'aide barreau sortir cette année
pour les fruits et légumes d'un côté
donc sera comme d'habitude un nouveau
bail à houat l'ex taux d'accords
d'habitude ce sera aussi largement
diffusé sur le site du département
franchement grâce à ce site est de 1 pb
à nous d'avancer mais qui peut donner de
notre culture mais s'ils avouent
pour retrouver toutes les informations
concernant les aides aux producteurs
indépendants de fruits et légumes
contacter la cellule d'accompagnement
des agriculteurs du département au
numéro vert 0 800 000 490 et sur un faux
point agricole @ cg974 point fr voilà le
département des générations c'est fini
et vous pouvez revoir cet épisode et les
précédents en replay sur nos sites et
réseaux sociaux je vous donne rendez
vous très vite pour un nouvel épisode à
bientôt
bonjour nos caves aujourd'hui mais ça va
rencontre une accueillante familiale à
sainte suzanne elle accompagne chésa et
des personnes en situation de handicap
c'est une belle mission pour les sortir
de l'isolément j'ai hâte d'en savoir
plus d'ailleurs j'y vais aller donne on
se tient au courant ok a très vite
[Musique]